it may have been a mild winter this year
but soaring energy bills mean millions
of people across the country are
struggling to heat their homes and this
is pushing households into debt take a
look at this it shows the number of
people on prepayment meters shot up by
an estimated 600 000 last year that's up
from 380 000 the previous year and why
does this matter well it's a sign that
people are struggling to pay their bills
households typically move to prepayment
meters when they fall behind on their
bills and it forces them to pay for
their energy up front but what happens
if they can't afford to top up well then
they risk being disconnected
and according to Citizens advice 3.2
million people ran out of credit on
their prepayment meters last year it's a
figure that's on the rise
energy suppliers have a big job on their
hands when it comes to supporting
struggling households because the number
of customers slipping into arrears is
growing you can see that here these are
households who have not yet found an
arrangement to pay back these debts you
can clearly see these lines creeping up
first during the pandemic and then as
energy bills rocketed after the
lockdowns
so levels of distress that are rising
among households but there are winners
to this just today shell announced
record profits of 40 billion dollars and
it's not alone
centrica recently lifted its earnings
guidance for 2022 the company made 1.3
billion pounds in profits during the
first half of last year that's up from
262 million the year before
but the same can't be said for energy
retailers who are also struggling with
Rising wholesale prices
profits of British gas which is owned by
centrica were down from 172 million in
the first half of 2021 to 98 million in
the first half of 2022
so there may be calls for energy
companies to do more to protect
customers but while some are making
bumper profits parts of the sector are
by no means immune to the energy crisis